con nuestro segundo invitado del día
vamos a hablar de la adicción a las
apuestas deportivas que se disparan con
el mundial de fútbol de Qatar aumentan
también la adicción al juego de las
personas cada vez más jóvenes uno de los
problemas para atacar esta delicada
situación es la normalización de este
comportamiento a nivel social como lo
estamos hablando también con más Romero
sala en múltiples publicidades que vemos
en estos partidos O cada vez más
frecuentes saludamos entonces a nuestro
segundo invitado del día él es Sergio
García Soriano eres psicólogo experto en
adicciones Gracias Sergio por estar con
nosotros esta mañana de lunes para
nosotros aquí en directo América de
Francia 24 también nos acompaña en el
estudio de nuestra periodista experta en
salud más Romero sala Buenos días Sergio
Muchas gracias por acompañarnos mira lo
primero que te queríamos preguntar Para
volver a hacer una pequeña
reintroducciones porque los juegos de
azar o las apuestas se pueden considerar
una adicción y comporta esta adicción
Buenos días a toda la audiencia
Gracias por
disminución importante pensar que uno
puede ser adicto a cualquier cosa por lo
tanto Antes había o a lo que hacíamos
era una nosología donde diferencia vamos
a aquellas adicciones que tenían que ver
con sustancias y después descubrimos las
adicciones que no tienen que ver con
sustancias Pero eso no las hace más
débiles o no las hace menos
perjudiciales tendríamos la adicción a
los juegos y tendríamos la adicción a
los
videojuegos por lo tanto las apuestas en
este momento debido al Mundial de Qatar
están en boga porque porque hay más
predisposición a estar mirando lo
deportivo y por lo tanto también está
abierta la puerta a hacer apuestas a de
alguna manera entrar en conflicto o
entrar en rivalidad para adivinar Cuál
es el premio Cuáles son los goles Y a
partir de ahí esa adicción o esas
personas que ya presentaban una
sintomatología en la cual había una gran
preocupación por lo económico ahí
también de alguna manera una gran
ambición porque piensan que invirtiendo
poco van a ganar grandes cantidades
cuando la realidad les muestra poco a
poco que eso no es así por lo tanto hay
en ellos un perfil determinado que desde
que acabó la pandemia tuvo también un
Boom el Boom fue que no podían acudir a
las casas de apuestas y por lo tanto
todo lo online y todo lo que tenía que
ver con las apuestas se incrementaron y
la población vulnerable fue la que más
lo sufrió por lo tanto tenemos que
darnos cuenta que en este momento el
mundial vuelve a revivir o vuelve a
hacer una alta frecuencia en aquellas
personas que ya tienen esa adicción a
los juegos claro cómo se puede hacer
Sergio para atacar esta problemática no
teniendo en cuenta que también uno de
los principales retos la normalización
del juego la normalización de las
apuestas sobre todo en los eventos
deportivos deportivos de Gran
envergadura como lo estamos hablando del
mundial en este caso del mundial de
Qatar
bueno estuve leyendo las declaraciones
que hacía el ministro de consumo Me
parece que son las adecuadas para que
esto no suceda tenemos que darle poca
cobertura A aquello que tiene que ver
con las apuestas de tal manera que sea
difícil sobre todo para las poblaciones
más vulnerables que son nuestros jóvenes
por lo tanto lo que no puede ser es que
tengan fácil acceso a este tipo de
ofertas o de cuestiones Por qué Porque
ya su vulnerabilidad interna la van a
ver potenciada por lo tanto en este
momento lo que tiene que suceder es que
aquellas personas que son más
vulnerables se tienen que hacer una
reflexión y tienen que encenderse la
señal de alarma el mundial es señal de
alarma para todas todos los adictos más
Los adictos al juego por lo tanto eso es
una medida y otra medida es ver cómo hay
que limitar las formas en las cuales las
personas tienen un fácil acceso al juego
Sí precisamente del online le quería
preguntar no cada vez es más fácil
acceder a este tipo de apuestas o de
comportamientos porque ya no solo
necesitas entrar a una casa de apuestas
o un lugar de juego si no es tan fácil
como hacerlo desde el ordenador Entonces
cómo se puede atacar por el lado online
y cómo lo que pues el internet ha
facilitado que se extiendan estos
comportamientos
claro es interesante ver que en muchas
de las páginas deportivas hay links a
apuestas por lo tanto lo primero que hay
que hacer es un tipo de normativa que
impida que cuando estoy leyendo mi
diario deportivo favorito en internet
luego directamente me aparezcan casas de
apuestas eso lo que hace es que corte la
frecuencia y la oportunidad que tiene el
joven para entrar dentro de la adicción
por otro lado también no tenemos que ser
ilusos el joven que lo padece tiene que
saber que en este momento es una crisis
para ellos en el sentido de que van a
tener más oportunidades y dentro del
perfil siempre hay un excesivo consumo
de información deportiva que es lo que
sucede que socialmente en las próximas
semanas ese excesivo consumo de
información deportiva estará bien visto
por lo tanto lo que decía anteriormente
una señal de alarma para todos aquellos
que
ha tenido una adicción y una adicción al
juego que es lo que sucede que cuando yo
busco la adrenalina constantemente y la
novedad esto también en las próximas
semanas va a ser así por lo tanto
socialmente parecería que se baja la
guardia Y eso es contraproducente para
Los adictos la regularización Sergio
sería la solución a este problema Y qué
tipo de medidas tiene que tomar entonces
las autoridades para regular todo este
tipo de apuestas sobre todo apuestas en
línea que cada vez van más en aumento
lo que se está haciendo hay que
no ponérselo fácil hay que intentar
quitar toda la publicidad pertinente
Aunque mueva mucho dinero pero es más
importante la salud de nuestros jóvenes
o la salud de los más vulnerables eso
por un lado luego por otro lado en
relación a la normativa tenemos que ver
que para que esto deje de suceder
Tampoco puede haber esos links de fácil
acceso también las casas de apuestas en
la mayor parte de los barrios y de los
barrios populares o de los barrios
de clases sociales
tampoco tener que tienen que tener unos
límites y unas normas no se puede entrar
sin dni es decir hay que registrarse de
tal manera que hay que poner una serie
de impedimentos o de límites que hagan
muralla y que impidan un fácil acceso a
esto por lo tanto habría que haber
legislación para que las casas de
apuestas no estuviesen cerca de los
colegios y pudiesen hacerlo donde
quieran y como quieran si estamos
hablando de en este caso de la
legislación en España pero pues no
aplica necesariamente a todos los países
tampoco de la región claro
latinoamericana yo quería preguntarle
estaba mencionando varias veces de esas
poblaciones más vulnerables no
particularmente los jóvenes pero también
la gente que vive en barrios más
populares de clases sociales populares y
quería preguntarle desde la psicología
Cómo se explica por qué son estos grupos
precisamente los que están más en riesgo
bueno porque tienen una ilusión de
cambiar de clase fácilmente con la
varita mágica y entonces viene el esa
ilusión que pueden tener ellos de
cambiar de clase y de tener todas sus
necesidades cubiertas
de pronto hay una ilusión que se muestra
en el marketing y se muestra la
publicidad que se la viene a taponar o
se la viene a regalar a dar sabiendo que
o pensando que no es una ilusión sino
que es una certeza por lo tanto van a
ser las
sociedades populares las clases
populares
más
frecuente que tengan este padecimiento
que tengan este trastorno porque porque
sus necesidades a priori no están
cubiertas y tienen una gran necesidad de
que sean cubiertas aquí ahora sin
tolerar la incertidumbre o sin hacer un
proyecto de vida para intentar salir de
esa clase social por lo tanto es una
ilusión que viene a taponar uno de los
pensamientos de la clase social claro
muy obviamente Sergio que podemos hacer
nosotros En caso de que una persona
cercana entre en estas dinámicas de
adicción
Bueno lo primero sería el que tenemos
que encender También nosotros la señal
de alarma y decirle Esto no puede ser
necesitas hablar con un especialista Por
qué Porque te está pasando esto esto y
esto tenemos que ser muy concretos muy
claros y que de alguna manera sea con
nuestra intervención que le interpelemos
y que le digamos que esto no puede ser
uno cuando está metido y es adicto lo
que hace es que suele abandonar su
trabajo suele abandonar la familia y por
lo tanto todo eso le va dando problemas
porque los juegos lo más importante en
su vida A partir de ahí nosotros lo que
tenemos que hacer es dar la señal de
alarma y llevarle a un especialista y
hacerle ver hacerle de espejo para
mostrarle lo que se está convirtiendo su
vida y no normalizar este problemática
No Omar por supuesto Y por supuesto es
que lo más importante es que nosotros
como sociedad nunca normalicemos esta
problemática es un problema muy serio Y
aunque no haya consumo de sustancias Ah
claro siempre haya consumo de sustancias
el
suficiente tiene una serie de síntomas
muy claros por lo tanto es un
padecimiento profundo y que no se puede
normalizar